we recently passed the 20,000 subscriber
milestone for this academic channel I'm
really excited about that and I wanted
to create a video specifically to say
thank you to all of our subscribers and
viewers followers everybody who shares
these videos but also to do a little bit
of reflection on what it means that this
kind of channel can actually succeed in
in this environment and and I wanted to
think about where we're going from here
as well I thought that could be some
interest to viewers so before I launch
into this I want to stress again thanks
very much I'm humbled by how many people
have you know not only written nice
things to me as messages or on the
channel or on Facebook or Google+ or all
these other places even in blog entries
but how many people have subscribed how
many people have shared these videos
it's really quite amazing to me this is
an academic channel and so I never
expected that it would get quite so much
traction particularly since when I first
began i was i was just shooting lecture
videos i've since gotten a little bit
more high tech you know what the
half-hour hagel videos and using little
bars underneath but for the most part
this is a very low tech substance over
style long lectures you know in an
environment where most people's videos
or anywhere from three to ten minutes
and people will watch these things all
the way through so I'm really happy
about that because what that means is
that if I'm doing my job well people are
actually engaging with philosophical
texts and thinkers and concepts and
movements and I'm able to play a role in
bringing that to them and and and in you
know widening education across the the
internet so you know for me this has
been a really cool thing in part because
academia is very stratified and we live
in a stratified society as well you know
where there's elites and they get to do
all sorts of cool interesting projects
they have all sorts of resource
is thrown at them and the rest of us you
have to compete for what often feels
like a shrinking pie the internet opens
up possibilities that are you know quite
different in that respect you know
there's there's really no limit to how
much could be put on YouTube I'm sure
there is someone that somebody will
correct me on that but for the for the
time being as far as philosophy videos
go it's it's wide open there's not
enough people doing high-quality work
that that people can use for classes or
for lifelong learning or for personal
enrichment and I've been you know really
happy to see that you know people have
used these videos as a resource for
their own development for their classes
some some people actually use them in
their curricula so you know what it
shows is if you if you care about what
you're doing and you know something
about what you're talking about and
you're willing to put in the work you
can reach an audience and you don't have
to be from MIT or Harvard or have a MOOC
or you know have have people backing you
or some foundation giving you a grant
you can just upload content and if it's
perceived as quality by people they're
going to use it share it and recommend
it so this has been a great experience
for me and it's it's turned into
something that I now recognize as
something like a calling I can't imagine
not doing this for at least the next 10
or 20 years so I wanted to talk a little
bit about the numbers themselves i
mentioned that we passed the 20,000
subscribers mark and that's really cool
in and of itself because it's a nice
round number you know but it's it's also
interesting we have nearly two million
views on these videos we have one hun or
we have 1 million eight hundred and
seventy thousand views that's a lot over
the last four or five years even more
staggering 18 million estimated minutes
have been watched of this
content so that's three hundred thousand
hours of instruction that people have
watched maybe some of it was actually
you know just putting it as background
noise or some of it was popping on and
then watching for five minutes and
getting off but a lot of that has been
people watching the entire way through
because the the analytics show that
people tend to watch these videos at
least to the halfway mark you know I
think that's being balanced up by people
get on and then get off so you know in
effect what that means is on one guy but
this YouTube capacity is like a massive
multiplier for for educational
possibilities because there's no way
that I could have myself provided three
hundred thousand hours of instruction
even if i was going to teach the rest of
my life in a college classroom even with
a you know say a class of 100 or 200
people it's just amazing you know that
that by putting something out there by
doing the work to you know talk to to an
audience that's not actually here you
can reach an audience and you know
affect education with this this massive
body of people who knows what the effect
of this is going to be ten years down
line or 20 years down the line another
thing that's kind of cool that I looked
up as far as stats was how many comments
have been made on these videos now some
of these comments are actually me when
I'm posting the video you know saying on
google+ hey here's a new video so you
gotta shave off let's say we shave off
650 because I've got about that many
videos posted right now and some of them
are me actually responding to other
people who said AI liked this video
saying all glad you liked it or you know
somebody saying hey I got a question
about this and then I try to answer the
question but we have on these videos
over 17,000 comments that means that
people have been engaging with these and
if you look at the older videos some of
them are still getting comments today
sidii owes
I shot four years ago on Plato or
Aristotle or Thomas Hobbes there's still
people engaging continuously it's I
don't want to say it's asynchronous
because people love that that sort of
word but rather there's no time ending
for for the education that's going on
there's always new people coming to it
so all that said that I think that's all
you know really cool developments but I
do want to do somewhat more extended
things so I want to say thanks to all of
all of my subscribers all more than
20,000 of you now for subscribing for
sharing the videos those of you who've
shared them on your facebook or twitter
or google+ or wherever else you're
sharing them some people use reddit I
don't use reddit but you know I guess
that's you know a good thing thanks for
all the comments that people have put
you've given me in some cases quite a
bit to think about many of you have
given me a boost up times when I needed
it when I was wondering if i was
actually doing the right thing and
spending so much time on producing this
content when I could be devoting it to
other things and thanks to all of you
who have suggested these videos as a
resource to your friends family fellow
students anybody else who you've you've
brought attention to with this sort of
stuff I have some special things that I
need to give as well the first one has
to go to my wife and partner in the
company reason I owed company devoted to
putting philosophy and practice the
company that actually puts these videos
out Andy Shaka she was the one who some
people you know heard this in other
videos she's the one who originally
pushed this idea with me who heard all
of my rationalizations for why it was a
bad idea why it would never work and who
just kept you know saying no you need to
try it i need to try it and who has been
supportive of me in this entire endeavor
every time that I've announced a new
project like the half hour Hagel project
like the existentialism class like like
a new channel on critical thank
she has been behind me saying you know
go to it I support you a hundred percent
so thanks to Andy for that i'd like to
also say thank you to my very active
subscribers and commenters there's
probably a good i would say a hundred to
two hundred people who over the years
have have engaged a lot with these
videos who have left a lot of comments i
mean if you go on my videos you'll see
it's really their names coming up and i
don't want to single anyone out because
i will inevitably leave some people out
so i just want to say those of you who
have been very engaged with these videos
thank you very much for that oftentimes
like I said it's given me support when I
needed it or some confirmation that this
is this is the right sort of activity
for me to be engaged in I'd also like to
say a special thank you for the backers
of the half-hour Hagel project and i
created a patreon page specifically to
support the production of the half-hour
Hagel videos which require an awful lot
of work on my part but which are
generating something that's going to be
of lasting significance and value for
decades to come so some people have
chosen to become Patrian backers and
they they contribute a certain amount
per video that has been really great to
see because it allows me to to make a
bit more of a living at doing this the
last things that i want to say on this
thank you video is that you know some
people have worried that I'm going to go
somewhere with this I don't think
there's any danger of me getting picked
up by a network or anything along those
lines this is an academic channel and
I'm not going anywhere even if I I do
have other endeavors you know I do
philosophical counseling I I you know
teach for other places I build courses I
do consulting but I think I'm you know
at least for the next ten years I'm
going to keep on putting a lot of my
effort into creating YouTube videos in
part because there's so much need for
high-quality videos in the area
philosophy and there's not an awful lot
of people who seem to be willing to
invest the time
I need to do that so I'm willing to do
that I've got some new channels that I
started this year one of them already
has a quite a few subscribers the
critical thinking logic and
argumentation channel i'll be adding
more videos to that as time goes on and
building that out like I've built up
this channel i also have a history of
philosophy channel that i haven't added
that much too but i will be later this
year so you know keep your eyes open for
that i'm going to be doing this for
years to come I've got a lot of really
cool projects planned beyond the
half-hour Hagel I'm thinking about doing
that sort of approach with other texts
like heidegger's being in time des
cartes meditations you know Aristotle's
metaphysics all sorts of things along
those those lines I'll be doing a lot
more core concept videos there's
existentialism videos get to shoot
there's a lot of cool content yet to
bring out but you know there's times is
the the factor there if I had 48 hours a
day I would actually be able to get as
much done as I want to get done but we
only get our 24 in any case once again
let me reiterate thanks to everybody who
has made this channel into a success
thanks to everybody who has subscribed
shared videos commented stick around I
hope that you'll stay engaged and that
you'll you know keep on commenting and
keep on sharing this stuff and that
you'll you know watch this for years to
come